Kate Bishop
Hi!
I made macaroni if you want some
Welcome back everyone this going to be my
full Marvel Hawkeye episode 5 video there
so many Easter Eggs so many big reveals, cameo
scenes we have to talk about.
So if you're brand-new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get everything also a
little bit of Spider-Man stuff happening this
week was Spider-Man no way home real quick
shout out to my friends AMC plus who asked
to sponsor this video.
You can catch all the walking dead universe
shows which always stream early on AMC+ like
fear the walking dead season seven they have
the entire latest seasons of the walking dead
world beyond and the main show the walking
dead season 11 part 1 all available to binge.
Season 11 part 2 will arrive in February.
So if you haven't caught up on all the current
seasons of the walking dead shows, be sure
to check it out AMC+ is available on all platforms
and devices.
So however you watch your TV you should be
good to go open a link for that service in
the description below but careful for spoilers
if you have not seen Hawkeye episode five
yet will be talk about everything is happen
the show so far will start at the beginning
go through shot by shot talk about Easter
eggs and moments.
Starting with the episode title ronin it's
a reference to Hawkeye's time as Ronin during
the five year time jump and how that's driving
a lot of the plot of the Hawkeye series.
The consequences of that and in present day,
it's a reference to him becoming ronin again
briefly putting on the costume in order to
save Kate Bishop and try to get echo to chill.
But the episode starts with a recap of the
black widow movie and yelena belova's back
story but it what happened to her after the
events of the black widow movie is a quick
audio montage is they pan up to her going
to try and save another black widow with a
bunch of audio taken from scenes in the black
widow movie just in case people did not see
the black widow movie.
But this is taking place in 2018 right after
the end of the black widow movie.
There's been a small time jump like yelling
the says that she's been going around the
world with her sisters the other black widows
that they rescued to try and save more of
drakov sleeper agents the black widows that
have been dosed up images all over the place
waiting to be called to active duty the funny
joke here being that when they go to save
this black widow here.
She reveals owner there was nothing wrong
with the.
I wasn't brainwashed I been acting as a mercenary
this whole time.
This house is mine.
I'm totally rich now because I been using
all my skills.
She even tells Yelena and her friend there,
you should be doing this to you should be
getting paid which is kind of help set up
her relationship with Val in present day because
the black widow post credit scene, seems like
it takes place obviously after she comes back
from being bullet.
But that's the idea.
She sort of references Natasha like hey how's
your sister doing when the woman asked about
her laugh about her fantasy to go moved to
New York City with Natasha and live his sisters
living the sex and the city kind of lifestyle.
But she's coming to her senses in the bathroom
kind of thinking about Natasha she gets snapped
confirming my theory that yelena belova got
snapped Natasha learned about it during avengers
endgame during the five year time jump in
that was one of the reasons why she was so
adamant that she sacrifice herself so that
she could bring her sister back the way they
play with the time jump is really cool to
the transition like it's almost as if no time is past
But really it's been five years.
But this other black widow that knows her
is like the best friend ever.
She's like all right look let me tell you
what happened last five years got myself a
family you need to go get yourself paid go
work as a mercenary your friend.
She left in a very different way the she's
getting paid right now you can stay with me
as long as you want, so there's any confusion
the black widow post credit scene takes place
a bit of a time jump after this scene here
because this is like right after she comes
back when she's being bullet back here.
This is literally right before the avengers
endgame final battle, so right after that
she would've gone to try and find Natasha
then learned that she had died the actual
present day of the episode doesn't pick up
till after Kate comes back to her mother's
house crying about what happened with Hawkeye
yelena belova and echo on the rooftop her
mother does show genuine care for her to like
her mother does love her issues that her mother
is been doing all this really shady stuff
that she hasn't totally revealed yet in this
whole conversation that she has consoling
her sort of sets that up that big betrayal
reveal at the end of the episode.
Like her mother's talking to her about how
her future is in over, but it might not wind
up being what she thought it would be and
how she can only move forward one datatype
how her path will wind around way she never
thought that it would is basically her mother
referencing her own back story and what happened
to her after the avengers movie the battle
of New York after they believe the Kate's
father had died and then she like the mother
had to find a way to support the family now
that led to her developing ties with the Mafia
kingpin Bishop security and all the shady
stuff that she's been tied up in with the
tracksuit's there is trying to make her mother
feel more sympathetic when they do make the full reveal
Like they kind reveal at the end of the episode.
Like you know what's going out they confirm
the connection to kingpin but she hasn't officially
had it out with Kate.
Like okay yes Kate I am responsible for all
this is also kind of seems like her mother's
trying to groom her the same way that shang
chi's father Wenwu was grooming him to join
the 10 rings the same way seems like kingpin
has been grooming echo misleading her about
what really happened to her father, then you
have all these because he and echo scenes
in the way they are together.
It seems like he does genuinely care about
her.
But by the end of the episode, you kind of
questioning his role in all this to like is.
He also in with the kingpin was he also partially
responsible for her father's death with the
way the actors playing it.
It does seem like he genuinely cares about
her even if he was an unwitting participant
in her father's death.
It doesn't seem like he did so knowingly and
then we get probably one of the best parts
of the episode.
I mean there couple really cool reveals it
was cool to see kingpin but yelena belova
and Kate Bishop having their quote unquote
girls night was probably one of the best parts
of the episode.
She comes back to her old apartment the got
trashed by the tracksuit's way back in episode
two yelena belova surprises or they are making
a whole bunch of mac & cheese they bond over
all kinds of stuff all the ways that you Lena
could have killed her if she wanted.
Like yeah you probably could kill me the instant
I walked in the room yeah I told he could
done that they bond over their mutual love
of dogs, because Yelena has a dog and she
knows that Kate Bishop ran into traffic to
say pizza dog.
She even tells Kate Bishop you want some points
with me because of that one you Lena references
red guardian when she says her daddy says
eating food is good for you in Florence Pugh
was fantastic effect she was probably one
of the best parts of the black widow movie
sweater that I was so excited to see what
she would be like on screen with some of these
other Marvel characters in the future the
MCU in this totally delivered on that promise
they have so much team up energy between the
two of them.
I hope that they get the team up again.
Pretty soon obviously we have the finale.
So maybe they'll team up a little bit during
that I'm talking about coming back in future
young avengers future thunderbolts projects
when she starts joking about all the touristy
things she wants to do in New York City because
it's the first time here.
The new and improved Statue of Liberty that
she's talking about is the one you see all
the Spider-Man no way home trailers with the
Captain America shield which they destroyed
during the Spider-Man No Way Home trailer
when she says she wants to visit Rockefeller
Center and Kate says it's amazing gift see
the big tree.
That's foreshadowing for their big final boss
fight that they happen all the trailers between
Hawkeye Kate yelena belova the tracksuit in
Rockefeller Center on the ice rink I love
her sense of humor so much like is this dry
Russian black widow sense of humor just so
utterly specific yet.
The picture you Lena having conversations
like this witty banter with all the other
avengers characters that are still around,
but they do get a little bit series when she
finally gets to what she's really doing here.
Like oh no I'm here to kill Hawkeye and you
Lena kind of gives her a reverse version of
the red on the ledger black widow speech from
the first avengers movie like Clint has so
much red on his ledger you can lay a trail
of blood that wraps around the world just
throw some doubt her away like she gets yelena
belova to question the motives of whoever
hired her to kill Hawkeye was sort of sets
up the payoff at the end with you Lena finding
out that was Kate's mother confirming all
our theories about that those pie when my
biggest theories like Sue pretty clear that
she was the one that hired her, which is because
she gave Kate that information doesn't mean
that she's going to stop trying to kill Hawkeye
that that's still a big problem that the deal
with in the finale.
And I think I've said this a few times, but
my theory was Kate's mother learned that Hawkeye
was Ronin using her Bishop security technology
or other informants and because she's working
with the kingpin the Mafia and they want revenge
on him for killing so many of their ranks
is ronin kingpin probably ordered Kate's mother
to take care clinical of the Hawkeye problem
and she just contracted the job out to Val
and her thunderbolts team and they decided
to use the Hawkeye black widow, yelena belova
connection against Hawkeye to motivate you
Lena to kill him even more.
I love the way that she leaves to she can
of yeets out the window with the same kind
of move that she is to jump off the building
with the tether it's the same black widow
tech that Natasha used on Clint to stop him
from sacrificing himself on vormir like she
tethered him to the clip so that he literally
couldn't sacrifice himself.
And while she's eating out the window the
black widow theme music starts playing again.
They play the black widow theme song, several
times during this episode.
Every time the either reference Natasha black
widow every time yelena belova is on screen,
it gets a lot of play during the episode back
grills apartment they reveal that he's been
watching pizza dog for Kate and Clint while
feeding him more slices of pizza that dog
is eating so much pizza during the series
when he references the new costumes that there
LARP her friends made for them those of the
comic book costumes they're wearing during
the big Rockefeller Center fight scenes in
all the trailers Hawkeye's is the one from
the Matt Fraction run and Kate Bishop's is
just a version of her comic book costume that
is pretty clear back in Kate's mother's house
that this whole FBI thing is just a ruse on
Kate's mother's part.
Like she's throwing Jack under the bus and
I love the way the he jokes about it to like
you're mistaken.
I've never worked a day in my life which I
actually think is the truth based on what
Armand was yelling at him about during episode
one, but was not clear.
Even though she's trying to deflect attention
from herself is whether or not Jack is actually
in on things like is swordsman actually complicit
with her or is he just her patsy.
But then later Hawkeye goes back to the site
of the very first avengers assemble scene.
Like when they do the big spin around avengers
assemble moment.
This is the site where that happened.
Like literally on the ground.
They put up a plaque right there.
The reason why he takes his hearing aid out
when he starts talking to Natasha kind of
talking to her spirit so to speak.
Everyone think about it is just to isolate
himself from the rest of the crowd on the
street to make the conversation with Natasha
feel more intimate when he says she was always
stubborn always had to win.
That's a reference to her beating him on vormir
for the honor who got to sacrifice themselves.
Like they had a knockdown drag out fight and
she stubbornly beat him.
That's why right after he references the soul
stone calling it a stupid orange rock is a
really heartfelt speech memorializing her,
and this feels like the speech that we would've
gotten had they done an actual funeral scene
for black widow during avengers endgame.
While he's talking they also play the black
widow theme music from vormir from her death
seen in the reason why he's apologizing for
what is about to do about during the Ronin
Sue back on pretending to be Ronin briefly
to trying to echo to chill, is that he's apologizing
for going back into that mindset again.
Like he already feel so much remorse for the
things that he did as Ronin during the five
year time jump all the people that he killed.
Even though they were bad people he's apologizing
for kind of going back on his word.
Like promising that he wouldn't be doing stuff
like this anymore.
Then of course they have that montage of Kate
Bishop getting over her sadness and just calling
Hawkeye again a billion times.
They bring back the joke about the coin flip
trick which he jokes about making mistakes
still learning.
She flips the coin breaking something offscreen.
I'm still learning the of a funny scene with
Ivan and Thomas beat boxing to run DMC's Christmas
in Hollis song, because it is Christmas time
and run DMC is a classic they of this big
pop-culture argument about which movie reference
or group they look like the most like imagine
real tendon bombs in the Sopranos because
their all groups of people in movies or TV
shows that war tracksuit's that funny moment
of Hawkeye leaving them, the note by shooting
it through their windshield so that echo will
show up at the fat man garage the site where
he killed her father during the five year
time jump and they still haven't completely
explain everything that might be going on
with his wife's back story this a lot of theories.
Maybe she winds up being a former shield agent
or she winds up being the MCU version of Mockingbird
who just retired in present day.
He talks about the big guy getting involved
which we now know as a confirm kingpin reference.
She clearly knows who that is.
So she knows all about the kingpin to and
they joke about her telling him to get it
done like what you're expecting me to tell
you not to do it and when she says she totally
understands more than anyone else ever could.
I think that that's Asaph confirmation that
she either used to be a shield agent or used
to do similar work herself she's has way too
many skills to be a common midwestern housewife,
so hopefully by the finale they will reveal
whatever's going on with her back story to
then back at the used car lot.
Like I said fat man with the red sign is another
daredevil kingpin reference.
Because red daredevil colors and fat man a.k.a.
kingpin he's huge have kind of a funny kind
of a badass takedown scene where the tracksuits
are all posted up around the lot waiting for Hawkeye
But he takes them out ninja style because
he's in the ronin gear.
So he's acting a little bit more like a ninja
and they do have a pretty solid fight scene
echo is able to hold them off.
But here's the thing I think that was part
of the point.
Like he didn't want to kill her as he literally
explain to her, I'm just here to let you know
that this is me.
I want you to see my face and know that I
will kill you if you don't back off then he
tries to reveal what was really going on what
was really behind the death of her father.
Like you're being misled you're being used
as a weapon the same way that I was.
I totally get it.
Your boss is using you misleading you.
And that's a huge reference to Echo's origin
story in the original daredevil comics.
So in those stories kingpin killed her father
and lied to her, saying that it was daredevil
training her as an assassin so that he could
use her against daredevil.
But eventually she learns the truth falls
in love with daredevil turns against kingpin
and because more of an antihero.
She also took the mantle of Ronin later in
the comics to the same way the Kate Bishop
eventually took the mantle of Hawkeye Hawkeye
says that the night that he killed her father.
He was only there because he was tipped off
by an informant working for her boss he's
talk about kingpin obviously we know now is
is that her boss kingpin was the person who
wanted her father did that's the reason why
he was killed.
So they're kind of trying to parallel the
Kate Bishop in the echo reveals here.
The big betrayals from family members people
that are close to them.
Like Kate Bishop learns that her mother is
behind all this is meant to feel like this
huge betrayal at the end of the episode in
out echo learning that possibly her uncle"
kingpin was really responsible for her father's
death is also meant to feel like this huge
betrayal echo managed to get the drop on Hawkeye.
But then Kate Bishop shows up explained that
she used her mother's tracking software probably
illegal tracking software lot a huge privacy
violations happening here to track him down.
And I love the joke about her plan to escape.
Like she literally just calls a regular old
uber using an assumed name echo then search
a suspect, because he was the mystery informant
that Hawkeye was referencing working for kingpin
who tipped him off the night that he killed
her father, claiming that he mysteriously
was in at the meeting when this all went down.
Like he was the number two in the organization.
So he should have been there when run was
tearing through the organization.
Like because he should be dead what they might
do because it seems like they wanted to feel
like because he genuinely cares about echo
is the kingpin may be just been manipulating
because he is well.
Then when Kate Bishop starts talking about
the girls night seen earlier in the episode
Hawkeye reveals he knows who yelena belova
is the black widow theme music plays again
I think is almost at the seventh time in the
episode.
They play the theme song elsewhere while yelena
belova is trailing Kate's mother to verify
that she was the one who hired her to kill
Hawkeye.
The building that she walks into here is a
meeting that she's having with kingpin the
pictures of her mother and kingpin that she
sends to Kate are being taken right here.
As they're speaking around the table and as
you see the reveal on her face.
They confirm the kingpin pictures vincent
d'onofrio's kingpin from the daredevil Netflix
series, he's back and he's wearing his trademark
white suit from the comics, which we also
see him wearing a version of during daredevil
season three in the finale the funny thing
to is that that building is the same building
from Hawkeye episode one where they were having
that gala event in the song that they go out
on as they make the kingpin cameo scene revealed
is the Grinch theme song the Grinch being
a reference to kingpin himself.
Like the Grinch during that story tried to
ruin Christmas in the kingpin it's implied
during this will ruin everyone's Christmas
ruin Hawkeye's promise to his family to make
it home in time for Christmas ruin Kate Bishop's
Christmas ruin echoes Christmas in the other
cool thing that they do with the end credits
if you watch the comic book looking credits
made to look like David Haas art from the
Matt fraction Hawkeye comic book run which,
but a lot of the plot of the series is taken
from.
While they're playing this Grinch song making
the kingpin references, you also see them
add this giant kingpin is shaped shadow over
the Hawkeye logo in Hawkeye and Kate Bishop's characters
As if he is now looming large over everyone
in the series.
This big overarching villain.
So will do a bigger kingpin daredevil video.
Soon, but basically the way Charlie Cox explained
when Kevin Feige was confirming the daredevil
characters from the Netflix series would come
back in the MCU.
He implied it would be kind of a reimagining
of the characters like they might reference
some of the plot elements from the Netflix
series.
But mostly, they'll be telling their own MCU
story using the same actors as those characters.
I boarded than a big video about what's happening
with all the daredevil netbooks characters
where they're all coming back and how they're
coming back in with their plans are for of
future daredevil Disney plus series, so I
the Link for that in the description below.
And yes I do think that there will be a bigger
kingpin cameo scene in the finale episode
six next week as part of the uncle kingpin
echo reveal and like I said I think it's meant
to be a parallel for Kate Bishop's reveal
about her mother.
Like all this huge betrayal from someone that
they were so close to so he spotted any other
big Easter eggs in the episode that I didn't
talk about during the video just right them
blown the comments my full Hawkeye episode
six video will post next Wednesday just like
normal probably post a full Spider-Man no
way home.
Review video next in then all my Spider-Man
No Way Home post credit scene videos Easter
eggs full breakdown videos will post after
that would be sure to go see that movie as
soon as possible do not wait everyone click
here for my no spoilers Spider-Man no way home
Review video and click here for my Hawkeye
daredevil video for how those characters are
coming back in the MCU.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!